one great thing about doing these shows  in New York is we've been lucky enough  to have a few real New York celebrities  in our audience and tonight is no  different ladies and gentlemen you'll  love this his pizza you love his pizza  ray from original Ray's pizza is here  and ladies and gentlemen ladies and  gentlemen sitting next to him is real  original ray right there  hey and look ladies and gentlemen  there's real famous original ray  right there there's real authentic  famous ray  check it out its famous Aboriginal ray  and of course not original or famous but  it it's 2:00 a.m. I'm drunk and I'm  hungry ray  raise give it  I think I know that last ray all too  well they'll all do real well do yeah  they're all miss my ass last race really  bailed me out  you